commerce ingénierie ou encore
agriculture choisir son orientation est
souvent synonyme de stress alors pour
accompagner les lycéens le salon de
l'étudiant a fait son grand retour au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
après l'ouverture de parcours suple le
17 janvier dernier étudiants et parents
étaient nombreux à venir découvrir les
formations ce salon principalement
permet aux étudiants et leurs parents de
s'informer d'être en contact direct avec
les écoles et donc du coup de pouvoir
avoir les conseils et d'être le mieux
aiguillé pour donc faire leur vœux par
la suite et choisir leur formation
postbac parmi les 70 exposants 40
établissements de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline c'est le cas de l'école
supérieure des agricultures de Guy
encour dont les formations attirent les
étudiants ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a
deux autres cycles qui sont moins rapide
Bachelor ça va être 3 ans alors ce sera
il y aura toujours du concret mais il y
aura un peu plus de théorique cette
fois-ci ça reste des métiers assez
importants c'est quand même la base de
la survie d'une société l'agriculture on
en a tous besoin et surtout dans le
contexte actuel contexte écon que et
surtout le contexte environnemental s'il
y a bien un truc que j'ai remarqué au
sein de la jeunesse en tout cas des gens
de mon âge à peu près c'est qu'il y a un
engouement qui se crée plus ou moins
autour du côté environnemental et pour
ceux qui se tourneraient vers le public
une université celle de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline membre de Paris
saclé on est quand même la seule
université présente ici les autres c'est
des écoles privées plus ou moins donc on
représente un peu le secteur public
aussi une diversité de formation qui a
attiré plus de 4000 étudiants étaient
présents cette année déjà venu il y a 2
ans et oui en vrai on retrouve assez
d'information et bah il y a beaucoup de
volontaires qui répondent à N à nos
questions des réponses auxquelles il
faudra répondre avant le 14 mars pour
les formations publiques date de clôture
de formulation des V sur parcours sup